Bernie Sanders shares some unfortunate
news with his followers the Israeli
election comes to an end and a
Democratic congressman spars with
Candace Owens I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show a lot to get to
today obviously the big news out of
Israel is that Bibi Netanyahu retains
the prime ministership for a fifth term
he has been prime minister for well over
a decade at this point Netanyahu has for
the fifth straight time surprised the
press in Israel which is constantly on
the left and has been routinely critical
and obviously the New York Times is very
unhappy about all this we'll get to all
of that in just one second first let's
talk about how you can have a more
calming sleep so I've said on the show
many times I am not good at sleep this
is why we have so many sponsors about
sleep all of them attempting to make my
sleep better well one of the sponsors
that makes my sleep better and better
every night is calming comfort so I've
tried this calming comfort blanket by
sharper image it's a luxurious weighted
blanket that helps you relax so you can
fall asleep and stay asleep naturally
it's designed with high density comfort
fill to provide exactly the right amount
of weight to help relax your body you're
not shifting around as much as your
sleep or rolling around or balling up
the blanket or anything like that it's a
it's made with a super soft velvety
material it is designed to promote a
sense of calmness and relaxation for a
more restful sleep when you're under the
blanket there's a feeling almost of
being hugged I mean there's an actual
weight to the blanket so you are
essentially being weighted down and that
means that you're not gonna be getting
all that nervous energy that you get
when you're trying to fall asleep it is
really fantastic I mean it's so good
that actually when I got a second one
because my wife liked it so much you can
sleep better and feel great and stress
like stress less also the common comfort
is a hundred percent machine washable it
is dryer safe it is it really is
fantastic I can't speak highly enough of
the calming comfort blanket right now it
comes with a 90 day anxiety free stress
free best night's sleep of your life
guarantee from sharper image right now
just for our listeners you can go to
calming comfort blanket to calm and you
use promo code Bennett check out sorce
15% off the displayed price again that
is calming a comfort blanket calm use
promo code bed and you get that special
deal because you can't put a price on a
great night's sleep go online right now
at calming a comfort blanket calm and
use promo code Ben for your special
discount today kid sizes are available
as well go check them out right now
calming come
blanket calm use promo code Ben and get
15% off the displayed price and again
there's a 90 day guarantee so you really
got nothing to lose give it a try it's
awesome you'll love it alrighty so the
big news of the day is obviously
Benjamin Netanyahu's victory in Israel
so with 96% of all the ballots in
Netanyahu retains the prime ministership
he essentially wins the same number of
seats as the so-called kovalev on party
the blue and white party and that party
was a Unity Party that was created these
things happen in Israel sometimes where
a Unity Party is created by a couple of
prominent figures just in time for the
election a while back
Arielle Sharon had left the the Likud
Party which is the right-wing party in
Israel and had created his own party
called Kadima and for a couple of
election cycles Kadima was an actual
thing and then it sort of fell apart the
two big parties historically in Israel
for people who don't follow Israeli
politics are Likud and labor labor has
completely fallen off the map the left
in Israel has fallen apart completely
the truth is that the blue and white
party is a censer party it is not a Left
Party which means that if you were to
view Israeli politics on a spectrum of
left to right well you actually see is
that something like 90 out of 120 seats
in the Israeli Knesset are
center-to-center right because the blue
and white party is not wildly divided
from Glee cooed especially on issues
like foreign policy another press we're
attempting to do this job where they
suggested that blue and white was
actually labor that blue and white the
Bennigan's party pentagons the former
IDF general yet your allah peed is a
sort of moderate former television host
in israel the idea was that this party
was the new labor that they were
peaceniks and if they had won the prime
ministership then there would certainly
be productive negotiations with the
Palestinian Authority in Hamas this is
absolutely untrue and it's not untrue
because the Israelis aren't transition
town negotiation it's untrue because
they literally have no one to negotiate
with it would I mean there's no one for
them to negotiate with who they're going
to negotiate with Hamas an actual
terrorist group that spends its days
figuring out how to build terror tunnels
to kidnap Israeli citizens and shooting
the people that presides over Hamas is
now in the 12 the 14th year of a
four-year term in the Gaza Strip Mahmoud
Abbas was last elected in 2005 in Judea
and Samaria in the West Bank
okay that that was
14 years ago at this point so we're
supposed to believe that that
anti-democratic terrorist force is going
to negotiate with Israel so the
Palestinian Authority a terrorist group
is supposed to negotiate with Israel
they've refused over and over Hamas is
not negotiating with Israel and the
Western press says why won't Israel
negotiate with these terrorists it truly
is astonishing there were a lot of
people I know who are on the political
right who are hoping that Netanyahu
would lose not because they dislike
Netanyahu but because they wanted the
rest of the world to see that the
so-called left in Israel can't even
negotiate with Palestinian terrorists
like the Palestinian Authority Islamic
Jihad and Hamas they wanted to give the
lie to the idea that it's just
BB's right-wing intransigence that is
leading to this breakdown in
negotiations it's not true it's a lie
but that is the line the media have
pursued they've demonized Netanyahu as a
racist and a bigot
they've demonized Netanyahu as a
trump-like figure even though Netanyahu
is a historic figure in the history of
Israel I mean he served as prime
minister in the 90s he was a Special
Forces operator in Israel his brother
famously was killed during the raid on
Entebbe Netanyahu is a real intellectual
I mean he went to MIT the whole attempt
to portray Netanyahu as a dictatorial
figure when he is trying to free up
economics has been elected multiple
times he's not longest-serving Prime
Minister in Israeli history it's an
obvious miss Reid from a left-wing press
in the United States that has true
animus against Israel and not just
against Netanyahu
that's why again a lot of people on the
right were saying they hope Netanyahu
loses just to expose the New York Times
for being anti Israel because they'd be
just as anti-israel with Bennigan's in
power for example now the New York Times
hilariously ran a headline last night
because the New York Times can be
counted on to get it wrong all the time
the New York Times ran a headline last
night suggesting that no matter how the
election turned out it was rebuked to
Netanyahu obviously false Netanyahu and
many of the exit polls was losing by
four to five seats when all the results
came in he is at the very least in a tie
with about thirty five seats in kanessa
with blue and white he may be at 36 and
blue and white at 35 but all the
right-wing parties were form a much
larger coalition than the left-wing
parties in the Arab parties in Israel
the Arab parties typically aligned with
the left in Israel because they're
hoping that Israel make concessions to
the Palestinians among other things the
New York Times reports that Netanyahu
was in position when a fourth
consecutive term on Wednesday with
nearly
all the votes counted they say the race
was extremely tight his main rival
Pentagon's also claimed victory now that
is not unusual because what happens in
Israel is the exit polls start to come
out really quickly everybody claims
victory and everybody can plausibly
claim victory because you never know how
the coalition's are going to shape up
the big surprise of the night actually
wasn't Netanyahu winning it was how many
of the bigger right-wing parties didn't
make the cutoff threshold so there was a
party called new right with Naftali
Bennet who's a big media figure over in
Israel and an shaked who is the former
justice minister in Israel and a real
rising star in Israeli politics they did
not make the cut off the suit party led
by Moshe Feiglin
did not make the cut off that was kind
of a surprise basically it seems that a
lot that because Netanyahu was
campaigning on the basis that the
Israeli left was in danger of taking
over a lot of people who would have
voted for right-wing splinter parties
instead shifted their vote to Likud
giving Netanyahu the lead the president
Rubin Rivlin is going to choose who
exactly gets to form a government the
way the government works in Israel is
that you form a coalition with a
majority in the Knesset and the
president has to decide who to hand the
opportunity to to form the coalition
typically it's pretty obvious you just
sort of look at where the parties
naturally align and then you say okay
these right-wing parties are going to
form a majority of the of the Knesset
and these left-wing parties can't form a
majority so we give it to the right wing
that's what has happened here now this
is hilarious
the New York Times says regardless of
the final result the election appeared
to be a grave scare for mr. Netanyahu
who has led Israel for a decade of
relative security and prosperity more
than a million Israelis voted for the
blue and white a record for a new party
placing it in a position of being the
main alternative to Israel's right wing
a spot held for decades by the Labour
Party well no this is more of a scare
for the Labour Party than it is for
Netanyahu who was hit with not one but
two indictments in the middle of this
election cycle unending hatred from the
left-wing press across the United States
and in Israel and pulled out a victory
anyway for the fifth consecutive term
okay that is not exactly a brutal scare
for Netanyahu the guy ended up winning
65 of the seats in Knesset which in
Knesset is a pretty solid majority
that's a pretty solid majority so the
parties that are lining up behind
Netanyahu that includes the right-wing
and religious parties and he will have a
majority in office that the four parties
to be cool on who the union of
right-wing parties the ultra-orthodox
which is really a Sephardic political
party and largely concerned with
preserving the benefits that that that
some Orthodox Jews receive in Israel and
United to our Judaism which is a
right-wing Israeli Orthodox party those
are combines want to combine 25 seats
and then the Easter l-bayt ah no party
led by a big door Lieberman which is
projected to take 5 seats as well now
the way this works is that Netanyahu
will then hands out cabinet ministries
to a bunch of his coalition partners so
it'll be it'll be interesting to see
what happens from here but the bottom
line is that the the press is going to
play this as though the evil Israeli
right-wing one here and that it's just
another sign that the Israelis are
unwilling to make concessions you can
see Chris Matthews did this routine
Chris Matthews he knows less about
Israeli politics then he knows about
cooking a good borscht I mean the guy
really doesn't know anything about
Israeli politics he gets out of bed in
the morning cuz there's a show come on
in there talk about a country I know
anything about you doesn't know anything
but you know what rolling in you're a
drunk looking crazy
Tuggle Israeli politics go president
droppers affords no deeper political
bond than with the one he has with besra
Netanyahu I I've been following the
Middle East like every grown up American
who lives in this country we all follow
middle these negotiations and politics
and always our president from Eisenhower
from all we have to w although some
leaned towards Israel more some leaned
against a little bit their government
they've always played this other role is
honest broker in the region so they can
bring peace and play a bigger global
role than just being buddies with Israel
this president has ignored his global
role ignored the role forfeited that a
peacemaker or honest broker and just
played political sidekick a BB okay
that's an amazing statement by Mathews
so basically all the other presidents
were great because they refused to
support Israel in their battle with
terrorism whereas Trump is very bad
because he has been a true solid ally to
the only democratic state in the Middle
East and we in the United States you can
tell how Israel has you know the only
free elections in the Middle East by the
fact that we in the United States can
watch as the results roll in in real
time and Bibi Netanyahu could have lost
this election canapé said anywhere else
in the Middle East of course not Israel
is a liberal democracy Israel is a free
country Israel is a country where all of
its citizens have
and yet people like Matthews wants he
want the United States to treat Israel
and the Palestinians on an even plane
when the Palestinians are led by
legitimately terrorist groups who have
not been elected for last 1415 years
it's pretty astonishing also worthwhile
noting you know you get Matthews
complaining there that trumpeter vanie
Israeli election now actually Trump
didn't intervene in the Israeli election
he's obviously friendly with Netanyahu
you know used to intervene regularly in
Israeli elections that would have been
Barack Obama and there's a great irony
to the fact that Obama who despised
Netanyahu is out of office he's termed
out by Netanyahu maintains his office
and Israel is now in stronger position
today than it was when Barack Obama was
in office Barack Obama spent his term
trying to hurt Bibi Netanyahu and trying
to hurt the State of Israel there's just
no question about this he was
exorbitantly anti-israel in his policies
there's a reason that right before he
left he abstained from a UN resolution
that he helped to push that condemned
Israel Obama would Obama actually
deployed members of his own political
coterie to Israel to stump against
Netanyahu in the election before this
one so we're gonna talk about American
interference in Israeli politics Trump
is not the beginning nor is he the end
it's really an astonishing take by the
left you can tell the left is very upset
about this because they don't like
Netanyahu period and by the way and as I
say it's all a lie they wouldn't like
Benny gaunts either they wouldn't they
wouldn't like anybody who's elected to
the prime ministership of Israel even
when Israel makes concessions the New
York Times never thinks it is enough
okay we'll get to a little bit more on
Israeli politics in a second and then
we'll move across the pond to American
politics but first let's make something
very clear you don't have time to go to
the post office I don't have time to go
to the post office you are busy no one's
got time for that traffic parking
lugging all your mail and packages it is
indeed a real hassle and that is why you
need stamps.com
it's one of the most popular time-saving
tools for small businesses why because
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices or an
online seller shipping out products or
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps comm can handle
all of it with ease simply use your
computer to print official US postage
24/7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
it once your mail is ready you just hand
it off to your mail carrier or you drop
it in the mailbox it is indeed that
simple with stamps calm
you get 5 cents off every first class
stamp up to 40% off Priority Mail not to
mention it is a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters stamps
comes a no-brainer it saves you time it
saves you money it's no wonder over
700,000 small businesses already used
stamps calm right now my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage ends digital
scale without any long-term commitments
there's a reason we use stamps calm at
the Daily wire offices you can too
just go to stamps calm click on that
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Shapiro that is stamps calm
enter Shapiro to check it out so as I
say the media coverage is just there
lamenting they can't handle the fact
that Bibi Netanyahu retains the
Premiership and his his fifth term what
really happened here here's what really
happened here as Damon linker points out
at the week there is no left in Israel
there's no left left in Israel
why because eventually reality sets in
when everyday you have to face the
prospect of rockets flying over your
cities because you unilaterally withdrew
and handed territory to a terrorist
group at a certain point people are
going to say you know what I don't think
we can make a deal with those folks we
need somebody who's going to guarantee
us security that's all that has happened
in Israel everyone in Israel right left
and center understands there has to be a
separation with the Palestinians the
only question is whether that separation
happens with more is territory under
Israeli control or less territory under
Israeli control everyone right left and
centre understands there cannot be an
independent Palestinian state in control
of its own borders so long as that state
is run by terrorists and it will form
the foreseeable future
you run by terrorist groups everyone
understands this that's because people
in Israel are reasonable that's because
they are humans they're humans who are
reasonable and I think that the vast
majority of Palestinians have either
been brainwashed by an education system
that has taught them that the Israelis
are the reason for their suffering
whereas if the Palestinian government
actually just came to the table this
would all end tomorrow
or the vast majority of Palestinians are
under the active oppression of terrorist
groups that are active in in the Gaza
Strip and the Palestinian Authority and
an under Islamic Jihad you can't blame
the Israelis who have tried to bend over
backwards at every step of the way every
single step of the way
name a list of concessions Palestinians
have made go oh you can't that's because
they've made no concessions
nimma list of concessions Israel has
made let's see they withdrew from the
entire Gaza Strip in 2005
they have withdrawn from well over 80%
of Judea and Samaria they have tried to
hand to wreak control over to the
Palestinian Authority routinely a hoot
Barak made an offer where he handed
tried to hand half of Jerusalem to the
Palestinian Authority who don't matter
tried to do exactly the same thing and
add something like 94% of all
territories asked and land swaps in
return for the other 6% which would have
been areas like a fraud heavily Jewish
territory Israel is constantly trying to
make concessions it's been rejected
every step of the way for literally the
entire history of Israel and yet the
left-wing press constantly is putting
the onus on the State of Israel which
suggests you that they don't understand
the politics or there is animus unique
animus for the State of Israel which is
driven by a perverse view of the world
and of global politics even if blue
annoyed and one that would not have been
in an endorsement of the leftist
position on Israel because blue and
white was not a Left Party was a central
party already
meanwhile the Democrats continued to
push forward their agenda and there's
something stunning a little bit about
Bernie Sanders and it occurred to me
yesterday so Bernie Sanders it turns out
is a millionaire he's a millionaire Wow
so he said that he was not gonna release
his tax returns then he said he was
going to release his tax returns his
finally acquiesced he told the New York
Times that he said April 15 is coming we
wanted to release ten years of tax
returns April 15th
counted nothing will be the can kill so
I think you will see them and then he
added he is contrasting his wealth with
that of President Trump not to being a
billionaire he said well your records
look like he said not being up there
look at that not having investments in
Saudi Arabia wherever he has investments
all over the world mine will be a little
bit more boring and then he conceded and
here's here's the best part here's the
best part
he conceded that he is a millionaire
that he's worth more than a million
dollars which puts him in the top
percent of wealth or wealth owners in
the United States and probably in the
top 1% of income between him and his
wife he says I wrote a best-selling book
if you read the best-selling book you
can be a millionaire too right that's
that's my point as I said yesterday
Bernie Sanders man marks in the streets
Hayek in the sheets in it
it's that's an amazing amazing thing
right Bernie Sanders the guy who's
constantly ripping on the free-market
system saying well if you work hard and
you write the book then you also could
be rich right that's what I say and
that's what President Trump says that's
what everybody who is right-of-center
says by the way that's what a lot of
people on the Left say to Hillary
Clinton has said that she is a
capitalist in 2016 there's a debate
between her and Sanders and Sanders said
he was asked whether he's a capitalist
and he said if by thought to mean am I
in favor of corporations that owned the
American political system - no I am NOT
the capitalist and then went to Hillary
and Hillary said yeah I'm a capitalist
because capitalism has created the
greatest middle class in the history of
the world Hillary was right Bernie was
wrong
but here's the dirty little secret about
Bernie Bernie wants it both ways
so they're a bunch of Democrats who
still like the capitalist system but
they just said that they want to
redistribute the gains right they want
it to be more like Norway they want to
be more like Denmark now Bernie says all
of that but then he proclaims that he is
a socialist and he doesn't like the free
market system because the truth is that
if Bernie's told the truth if Bernie
actually said the same thing as all the
other Democrats that he likes capitalism
he just wants to quote unquote Corbett's
excesses or that he wants to stack more
welfare programs on top then people
would understand that his program is
actually not substantially different
from the rest of the Democratic Party
his differentiating point is his dislike
for the profit motive in capitalism that
is his differentiating point if he
doesn't do that he is exactly the same
as Joe Biden he is a little bit more
extreme in his in his government
nationalization scheme but his basic
take would be the same as the mainstream
Democratic Party he couldn't really
claim independence from that party he
couldn't claim to be an outsider if his
argument was the same as the rest of the
Democrats capitalism free markets
inherently good but we have to make sure
that people are taken care of he is no
different from any other Democrat but
that is not his case that is not his
case and that's what makes it ridiculous
and hypocritical for him to say that if
you publish a book you can be a
millionaire too now a couple of things
that are also noteworthy about this
Bernie Sanders is not a millionaire
because he wrote a book Bernie Sanders
is a millionaire because he has lived
off of government largesse his entire
life and he wrote a book meaning that
Bernie Sanders has been a professional
useless person from virtually all of his
adult life I mean the man was so lazy he
was tossed off a commune in the 1970s
you know late
you have to be to be tossed out of a
commune hey so Bernie Sanders has been
in the public eye elected official being
paid by the taxpayers for virtually all
of his 60 years in the in the work force
because the man's nearing 80 and using
that platform he then launched a book
that sold a lot of copies so using the
platform of a taxpayer-funded position
to become prominent and then launching a
book on the back of that is not exactly
the same thing as somebody like me
launching a book and that's selling a
lot of copies I have taken no taxpayer
dollars I have not forcibly extracted
wealth from anyone and then put it in my
pocket
hey Bernie Sanders is in the business of
taking taxpayer dollars he didn't build
that to coin a term but beyond that
Bernie Sanders again his record is that
he is I mean this sudden love for an EIN
Randian approach to the free market if
you write a book you can also be a
millionaire inspiring message they're
capitalists unlike Warren Buffett or
Bill Gates Sanders doesn't generally
spend a lot of time paying homage to
free markets like if you listen Warren
Buffett Buffett will talk Buffett is on
the left he's a Democrat he'll say free
markets a wonderful capitalism is
wonderful also people like me should be
taxed more to pay for welfare benefits I
disagree with him I think this is
counterproductive I think it's a
violation of the sovereignty of private
property to forcibly remove wealth from
people so that you can spend it on stuff
that you want but at least Bill Gates
and Warren Buffett are fans of the free
market Bernie Sanders has spent most of
his career ripping on the free market
the only time he occasionally pays lip
service to capitalism is to swivel and
call for nationalization of major
sectors of the American economy in the
70s he urged nationalization of nearly
every major industry in the United
States from oil to banking in 1988 he
explained that his brand of socialism
revolved around a system quote while
human beings can own the means of
production and work together rather than
having to walk us to my slaves to other
people who can hire and fire that's
communism own ownership of the means of
production is the Marxist definition of
socialism during that same period he was
asked about bread lines in Nicaragua
which was then run by communists in
Sanders said it's funny sometimes
American journalists talk about the
about how by the country is that people
lining up for food and this a good thing
in other countries people don't line up
for food the rich get the food and the
poor starve to death
Sanders his entire critique of
capitalism is that in it inherently
causes inequality and that that
inequality
leads to domination by the rich at the
expense of the poor that is his critique
of capitalism so if that's our critique
dude you don't get to play the I worked
hard for my money card you don't get to
do that routine so welcome to the club
Bernie Sanders I'm so glad that you've
decided to come around to the free
market perspective it is amazing now
they the left will simply ignore all of
this his supporters will simply ignore
all of us or they'll do the routine
where they say yeah well he never said
that he hates all of capitalism that's
been the underlying theme of his
campaign for ever it's the
differentiating point again between him
and Hillary Clinton it was funny people
on the Left were struggling to come up
with a differentiation in 2016 between
Sanders and Clinton and basically this
was the common consensus that in his
heart Sanders does not like the free
market Hillary Clinton does like the
free market and Hillary herself has said
and one of the reasons that I lost in
2016 is because I had the gall to come
out in favor of capitalism so
fascinating to watch Bernie Sanders
being exposed for what he really is
which is apparently a typical mainline
Democrat not a brand-new revolutionary
leftist pretty pretty incredible okay in
just a second we'll get to the rest of
the positive Democratic agenda so today
we're going to break down the Democratic
agenda into three separate prongs
there's the positive Democratic agenda
the negative Democratic agenda and then
the delusional Democratic agenda so
we'll get to all of those in just a
second first let's talk about how you
can make your business better like
Bernie Sanders you love the free market
and you want to make sure that you have
the best people working for you and this
is why you should use zip recruiter zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technologies zip recruiter
scans thousands of resumes to find
people with the right experience and
invites them to apply to your job has
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match zipper career is so effective that
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire that is zip recruiter dot-com slash
a daily Wire Dai ly WI re zip recruiter
comm slash daily Wire zip recruiters
indeed the smartest way to hire if
you're looking to upgrade staff or if
you're simply looking to bring on great
new people
zip recruiter is the place to start go
check them out right now at zip
recruiter comm slash daily
where he can try zip recruiter for free
zip recruiter comm the smartest way to
hire go check them out one more time
being tried for free zip recruiters comm
slash daily wire all righty so meanwhile
the Democrats are rolling out their
positive agenda suffice it to say it
ain't that great mazie Hirono who may in
fact be the new dumbest person in the
United States Senate Barbara Boxer used
to hold that title and then she retired
now it is mazie Hirono the senator from
Hawaii so she was talking about the
abortion agenda of the Democratic Party
and she said you know what let's not
focus on the unborn children let's focus
on the children who are already here the
word hypocritical doesn't even begin to
cover what is happening to women and
children across our country my thanks to
you dr. Peterson and Senator Jordan
today once again and I hope the
supporters of bills that were talking
about today both in the station and
Congress turned their efforts to
improving the lives of the children who
are very much here already and who are
so poorly served by the Trump
administration and his policies okay
pretty amazing so don't focus on the
babies in the womb that are being killed
focus on the other kids again I don't
know why this is a binary decision how
about we focus on both I feel like we
can walk and chew gum at the same time I
feel like we can preserve the lives of
babies in the womb and also treat people
with humanity at the border I don't
think these things are mutually
exclusive so your positive agenda is
treat people at the border well forget
about the babies being stabbed in the
head and the brain sucked into a sink
like the solid solid stuff they're
amazing in rona meanwhile I got a OC who
says that there will be blood on our
hands if we don't pass her a crappy
green new deal that we are not allowed
to vote on I mean I do love the fact
that aoc who is incredibly fresh and
incredibly face as we know that she put
forward a green new deal so unpopular
that every co-sponsor of it voted to
abstain from passing it in the United
States Senate and then she has the
temerity to come out and say if we don't
pass my green new deal that I encourage
people to abstain from then we have
blood on our hands okay ladies so put it
up for a vote I'm you were why are you
angry when people vote on your stuff
there's aoc doing this routine the
positive agenda here do you think that
neglecting to address these threats is
could contribute to American the loss of
American life yes
and do you think that denial or even
delaying in that action could cost us
American lives yes so I think what we
have laid out here is a very clear moral
problem and in terms of leadership if we
fail to act or even if we delay in
acting we will have blood on our hands
okay so the you know it's funny when
people on the right say stuff like this
if you say that if we fail to act on
abortion we have blood on our hands then
the left suggests that this is in it's
that this is an incentive to violence if
a OC says that we have blood on our
hands if we don't do exactly what she
wants to do that is not an incentive to
violence
even though legitimately this is I mean
this was really what the Bernie Sanders
supporter who shot up a congressional
baseball game said about climate change
he said that these people are trying to
kill us because they won't do anything
about climate change so I need to step
in and do something about them Bernie
Sanders wasn't to blame for that
AOC isn't to blame for people who do
violence in her name obviously she's not
calling for violence but that said is
this rhetoric dramatically overheated
she hasn't even put forward a practical
policy what exactly are we supposed to
be doing one of my pet peeves is people
who suggest that without any actual
policy I'm supposed to agree with them
they just wave around this this weird
bloody bloody flag where they where they
where they just sort of say if you
disagree with me on this general idea
then you have blood on your hands McCoy
I can't boil that down into anything the
Democrats did this as I said yesterday
about slavery reparations if you
disagree about slavery reparations then
this means you're anti blacks like
that's not a proposal you've not
proposed anything how am I supposed to
agree or disagree before you propose
anything but this is the the positive
Democratic agenda is that we need a
green new deal that is unspecified and
we need to ignore the death of babies in
the womb then there's a negative
Democratic agenda and this is really
where Democrats are seeking to make a
Democrats are hoping that they can win
election in 2020 simply by ripping on
Republicans that's all and so this means
that even the most quote-unquote
moderate and kind Democrats are going to
do this routine one of the people who's
been doing this to my great
consternation is Pete bada Josh so
Buddha says who's the South Bend Indiana
mayor I've had praise for him over the
past several weeks because I say hey
look a normal human a human who thinks
that just because we disagree that does
not make us a bad person
and yet Budi judge has spent the last
several weeks ripping on my pens for no
reason that I can fathom legitimately no
reason instead of him just saying listen
I disagree with Mike Pence on policy I
think that he's wrong and I think his
policies hurt people instead of that he
says Mike Pence hates me Mike Pence is
is despicable and a bad Christian and he
hates me and all Pence has done I mean
really all pens has done is say nice
things about Buddha judge his entire
career in 2014 when Buddha shesh was
called up in the National Guard
pence personally called him to express
his things in 2015 when Buddha shesh
came out of the closet pence said that
he was a good man I mean what is this
now the media want to create the feeling
there's a battle here so it doesn't look
like Buddha Josh is just being
aggressive for political gain so it
doesn't look like Buddha she's just
being a jerk attacking pence for no
reason
simply so he can claim that he's a
victim of pence who's never said a bad
word about him or done anything bad to
him
so CNN politics in their inimitably
stupid way massive journalism in
journalism in out the wazoo CNN politics
puts out this headline the feud between
mayor Pete but a judge and Vice
President Mike Pence escalates there is
no feud the entire feud is Mike Pence
sits there and Buddha shesh calls him
names that's not a feud I understand you
want there to be a feud so you can
portray pence as anti-gay but there is
no feud there is no feud at all by the
way if you think that CNN doesn't have
bias CNN has been trying to has been
trying to ramp up the rhetoric on the
immigration issue suggesting the
president Trump is uniquely evil when it
comes to separating families at the
border now obviously Barack Obama also
separated families at the border because
he had you under 9th Circuit Court of
Appeals law nonetheless CNN has on
Samantha vino grad now you may not know
Samantha Vina grad she was a member of
Obama's team she was not Chiron as such
on CNN she was just a CNN contributor
and here she is on CNN explaining that
when Obama separated families that was
good for the families when Trump
separates families that's bad for the
families separated children from their
families wolf or from adult wealth it
was for their protection it was if there
was a risk of trafficking or other kind
of harm that might have been incurred
but he
if he did do that why is Donald Trump
saying that two wrongs make right again
Obama wasn't wrong but so he's saying
that because something happened under
President Obama he's repeating in upping
the ante that is an incredibly poor
excuse he is systemized that inhumane
treatment that again Obama was doing a
protectorate oh so when Obama did it it
was to protect the kids
but when Trump does is cuz he hates the
kids amazing journalism in Siena and
just well done all around and the
attacks don't stop there I'll bring you
some more of these attacks and I'll
bring you an epic moment from Candis
Owens who did an amazing job in firing
back on Democrats who attacked her
yesterday on the hill I'll get to that
in just one second first head on over to
Daily wire for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription that means that you get
the rest of this show live means you get
two additional hours of the show every
afternoon which is just pleasures galore
I mean your life will be so much richer
you can go check all of that out also
for $99 a year you get this the very
greatest and beverage vessels were on
the road today as you know but I have
activated the non invisibility cloak
device I've deactivated the cloaking
device on our on our leftist here's hot
or cold tumblr and thus it stands before
you in my hand you can have one of these
for $99 a year which is cheaper than the
monthly subscription all sorts of other
benefits you get the Android clave and
show you get the mat well show you get
Michel moles to show if that's something
you actually care about you get all of
those wonderful things when you
subscribe also subscribe to us at
YouTube and iTunes and you get the
Sunday special you get all sorts of you
get the conversation with me when you're
a subscriber you can ask me questions
and the benefits are just enormous the
drawbacks nearly non-existent so go
check that out right now over at daily
we're calm we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so the positive Democratic platform is
slavery reparations a unspecified how
that works green New Deal unspecified
how that works
and also kill babies pretty obvious how
that works the negative Democratic
agenda is Mike Pence is evil good luck
with that when Obama separated families
that was for their own good but Trump is
a bad man and also Stephen Miller is a
white nationalist so Stacey Abrams who
has become a really bad actor on the
American political stage he's a good
speaker she's a charismatic figure and
she's a bad actor she's spent every day
since losing her Georgia gubernatorial
election proclaiming that it was stolen
from her I'm old enough to remember when
the media said that if Trump did that it
would be a cut against both the American
Way of life in the democratic system and
the media they covered it now Stacey
Abrams has the kind of stuff daily and
the media feed her for it and talk about
her running for president Stacey Abrams
appears on CNN and calls Stephen Miller
the president's immigration adviser a
white nationalist what is her evidence
that he's a white nationalist that she
that he disagrees with her obviously
congresswoman Ilhan Omar actually
referred to him as a white nationalist
do you agree with her I believe that
what we have seen from Stephen Miller is
vestiges of white nationalism one of the
deepest concerns that I have that this
is a person who's directing the
Department of Homeland Security the
third largest agency in the in this
nation that's responsible for protecting
us but the person who is pulling the
strings does not seem to care about
protecting many Americans really so
Stephen Noor doesn't care about
protecting Americans and she gets this
from no one knows and also he's acting
vestiges of white nationalism based on
hmm but I guess that we can just yell at
everybody who's republican and called
them racist the best example of this was
yesterday on the hill so Candace Owens
was speaking at a white nationalism
hearing on the hill by Democrats in
Congress now everyone should be
concerned with white nationalism the
white supremacism they are very bad
they're so evil that I have to have
nearly full-time security around me
because they hate my guts and I hate
their guts my hatred is justified
there's an unjustified but they're bad
people so that's all right white
supremacism is evil racism is evil white
nationalism is evil we are all unified
on this the
the Democrats on the hill we're having
this hearing however was to suggest that
white nationalism is on the rise because
conservatives have been winning
elections that is because of Trump that
is because of the great expansion of
white nationalism in the United States
on the basis of conservatism and then
the left was going to Democrats were
gonna try and conflate sort of
mainstream conservatism with white
nationalism which is a bad faith tactic
designed not to unify us but to tear us
apart so Candace Owens goes and she
testifies and she talks about and she
talks about how the Democrats are using
this tactic that what they are really
trying to do is scare minorities and
devoting for them by suggesting that if
Republicans win then they will be a
danger of being attacked in the streets
justice Millette style and Candis is not
wrong about that that is obviously a
political tactic that is being used by
Democrats I take white supremacy
absolutely seriously I take white
nationalism absolutely seriously is also
true that on a factual level a lot of
the statistics that have been put out
about the rise in white nationalist
crime are based on changing the method
of statistic gathering more reporting
agencies have been reporting hey alleged
hate crimes and therefore the numbers
have been going up the truth is that
they were going up year on year before
President Trump ever entered the White
House with all of that said Candis Owens
was speaking about all of this and then
sort of the broader democratic political
agenda and Ted Lou who is just awful the
Congress person from Los Angeles he
pulls out a video on his phone of Candis
Owens talking about Hitler now this made
a controversy about a couple of months
ago where she was giving some sort of
speech and she was talking about
nationalism she was asked what what she
thought of nationalism and she made an
ill-advised and poorly articulated
statement about how Hitler's big problem
is that he was imperialist not a
nationalist meaning that nationalism is
about pride in your state and trying to
build up your state and imperialism is
about trying to spread those values
outward and take over other states and
she used Hitler as an example and it was
a very poor example because obviously
Hitler's crimes began in Germany with
the repression and murder of his own
citizens now I think that that error did
not come from Candace Owens being a fan
of Hitler I think to suggest that
Candace Owens is a fan of Hitler is
fanciful at best and obviously obviously
slanderous at worst but it was it a
badly articulated say me I was it was it
was a
bad badly articulated statements ted
Lieu pulls out this clip to try and
demonstrate the Candace Owens Candace
Owens is somehow a person who is
inspiring white supremacy all over the
world this black woman is somehow
world because she made an ill-advised
statement about the difference between
nationalism and imperialism and used
Hitler as a poor example here's Lou
doing that and then Canada so uns
clocking him when people try to
legitimize Adolf Hitler does that feed
into white nationalist ideology I think
it's pretty apparent that mr. lube
believes that black people are stupid
and will not pursue the full clip in its
entirety he purposely presented an
extract extracted slip this will suspend
for a moment the witness will not do
that again
witness may continue sure even though I
was called despicable witness may not
refer to remember the committee is
stupid
I didn't refer to him as stupid that's
not what I said that's not what I said
at all as I said he is assuming that
black people will not go pursue the full
- our clip that was unbelievably
dishonest and he did not allow me to
respond to it which is worrisome and
should tell you a lot about where people
are today in terms of trying to drum up
narratives hey and she is exactly right
i mean that is candace owens at her best
when candice is good she's really good
and that was and that was really great
by Candice Owens you know when when she
was correct ted Lieu plays the clip he
doesn't even allow her to respond to the
clip he just leaves it out there and
then a Republican had to come back to
Canada so as to allow her to respond to
the clip and this justifies what she was
saying about the hearing that what the
hearing was actually designed to do was
lumping conservatives with white
nationalists that they can smear
everybody as a member of the white
nationalist movement I'm out right
Candice's all right everybody's alright
and white nationalist it's absurd it's
absurd but this is part of the Democrats
negative agenda everybody who disagrees
with me is a homophobe and a racist and
a bigot and a white nationalist it's a
bunch of garbage but this is what
Democrats are going to try to do that is
a scare tactic and it's a nasty scare
tactic at that and the best example of
this also came from this hearing Mort
Klein who's the head of the Zionist
Organization of America was called to
testify and Klein started to point out
that by the way you guys are totally
fine on the Democratic side with
anti-semitism right you have a person
sitting in this committee right now
Ilhan omar who's an anti-semite
Democrats immediately cut him off Jews
are the victims of 60
of the religious motivate to hate crimes
in America Jew hatred is the canary in
the coalmine
it's unfortunate incumbent upon us to
speak about the major issue threatening
violence against Jews and all Americans
which is Muslim anti-semitism especially
at Colorado palate I saw drivers I was
horrified to see speaker Pelosi leader
Hoyer defend represent of Oh more after
her vicious anti-semitic remarks
gentleman's time has expired
miss Owens that was unfair it was not
unfair yet plenty of extra time no okay
Jerri nail it protecting his own party
from allegations of going easy on
anti-semitism which is obviously
obviously true no this isn't partisan
hackery doll that's just the Democrats
are deeply concerned about white
supremacy that's that's really what this
is all about it's a fully Maday 'td
hearing that's obviously what was
happening here okay we'll get to the
delusional Democratic agenda so there
there is the so we've gone through the
positive Democratic agenda abortion and
green New Deal and slavery reparations
there's the negative Democratic agenda
Mike Pence is bigoted Stephen Miller is
white nationalist and Katniss Owens is a
Nazi and now we get to the delusional
Democratic agenda which is Democrats
still desperately hoping that robert
muller will save them from themselves at
the mullet report will emerge and that
when it does magically it will say the
opposite of what the Attorney General
has said that it says which is that
there was no collusion and that there
wasn't sufficient evidence for an
obstruction of justice charge Chelsea
Handler who I don't even know why she
started getting into politics yeah I
have a rule about comedians and politics
generally that is that comedians who do
politics are usually like C or D level
political commentators and they're a
comedians well if you mix your comedy
with your D level politics you're a
comedy with your d level politics it
just ends up being a C it's one of the
reasons why sometimes the show is funny
I am NOT a comic I'm a political
commentator I think my political
commentator ship is pretty good my
comedy so-so but if you mix the two you
end up with something that is closer to
so-so then something that is that is
really good Chelsea Handler is a perfect
example as she ends up on the view
talking politics and I'm she is not good
at it what is this I hear that you have
a crush on Robert Muller
one type there's always attractive we
have no idea who he is what he is he
could be the most boring person I know I
wanted boring at this point I mean when
you put him up against who he's you know
going after going after then yes I'm
sexually vibrating all for that and I
like that he crosses his keys and he
jocks his eyes and we have to see the
full report and until we see a full
report we won't know how attracted I am
oh so once she finds out whether he's
going after Trump then Shomo whether she
sexually attracted so so much humor Wow
comedy of epic levels happening from
from Chelsea Handler right there by the
way it is worthwhile note admit the
Attorney General is now going to engage
in a probe of the of the initial
investigation into President Trump
Attorney General Barr said on Wednesday
that he thought that spying on a
political campaign did occur in the
course of intelligence agencies
investigations into Russian interference
in the 2016 election this is according
to the Washington Post at a hearing
before the Senate Appropriations
Committee Barr was asked about his
statement a day earlier that he would
review how the FBI launched its
counterintelligence investigation that
sought to determine whether Donald
Trump's associates were interacting with
Russians during the 2016 presidential
campaign he said I think spying on a
political campaign is a big deal it's a
big deal he said there were long-held
rules to prevent intelligence agencies
from collecting information on domestic
political figures he's saying I'm not
suggesting that those rules were
violated but I think it's important to
look at that I'm not talking about the
FBI necessarily but intelligence
agencies more broadly and then jeanne
Shaheen the senator from New Hampshire
she asked you're not suggesting spying
occurred Barr said I think spying did
occur yes I think spying did occur
although he added that the key question
and this is correct is whether law
enforcement officials had a proper legal
justification to open such an
investigation and intelligence gathering
he says I need to explore that I want to
say that I'm reviewing this I haven't
set up a team yet I also want to make
clear this is not launching an
investigation of the FBI frankly to the
extent that there were any issues at the
FBI I do not view it as a problem that's
endemic to the FBI I think there was
probably a failure among a group of
leaders there in the upper echelon this
is exactly what I have said about the
the scandal of members of the FBI Peter
struck Lisa Paige James Comey members of
the FBI skewing their coverage of
particular political events
meet a narrative that the Obama
administration wanted to meet whether
you're talking about the Hillary
investigation or the Trump investigation
current and former law enforcement
officials of course have defended their
handling of the Russia investigation
saying it was carefully handled based on
available evidence and they've firmly
denied they engaged in political spying
we will see if this is true or not Barr
said that the review could result in
scrutiny of senior FBI official conduct
he said I feel I have an obligation to
make sure that government power is not
abused I think that is one of the
principal roles of the Attorney General
the Washington Post of course speculates
that this is all about Barr appeasing
Trump although the reality is that there
are serious questions that need to be
asked about the conduct of the Trump
investigation given that it dragged on
for two years and that there wasn't
sufficient evidence to bring a
prosecution or in fact any evidence or
in fact any evidence at all that the
president openly colluded with the
Russians during the 2016 election now I
have to bring you this story just
because it's hilarious apparently
President Trump visited Mount Vernon
yesterday and it was amazing or actually
was last April I guess the report is
only emerging now apparently during a
guided tour of Mount Vernon last April
with French president Emmanuel macron
thus according to Politico president
Trump learned that Washington was one of
the major real estate speculators of
Zera so he couldn't understand why
America's first president didn't name
his historic Virginia compound or any
other property he acquired after himself
according to three sources briefed on
the exchange from said if he was mad he
would have put his name on it you got to
put your name on stuff or no one
remembers you yes clearly none did the
VIP tour for the evening
Mount Vernon president CEO Doug Bradburn
been told Trump that Washington did
after all succeed in getting the
nation's capital named after him and
Trump said goodbye spectacular
apparently now that wasn't the only
hilarious comment that he made the
president's disinterest in Washington
made it tough for the tour guide
Bradburn to sustain Trump's interest
during into Luck's 45-minute tour of the
property which he later described to
associates as truly bizarre the macarons
Bradburn has told several people were
far more knowledgeable about the history
of the property than the president a
former history professor of the ph.d
Bradburn was desperately trying to get
Trump interested in Washington's house
said a source familiar with the visit so
he spoke in terms Trump understands best
telling the president that Washington
was an 18th century real estate Titan
who acquired property throughout
Virginia and what would come to be known
as Washington DC Trump then asked
whether Washington was really rich
according to a second person familiar
with the visit in fact Washington was
indeed incredibly wealthy part of that
is that the widow that he married Mary
Custis was incredibly wealthy this is
what Trump was really the most excited
about the person said apparently if
Trump was impressed with the route with
Washington's real estate instincts he
was less taken by Mount Vernon itself
which the first president personally
expanded from a modest one and a half
story home into an 11,000 square-foot
mansion the rooms Trump said were too
small the staircase is too narrow and he
even spotted some unevenness in the
floorboards according to for sources
briefed on his comments he said he could
have built the place better and for less
money
that's our president ladies and
gentlemen solid solid stuff from the
president to me my goodness okay where
we're living inside a comedy there's
just no only the father of our country
but the flower birds here the little any
event if I were living in 1787 I would
have built this totally differently I
nobody named it Trump house Trump had
big team on the front of Trump house and
then people would have remembered me as
opposed to George what who in remembers
George Washington anymore he's a state
named after him the capital named after
him the Washington Monument named after
him a couple of sports teams but you
know all right whatever who cares did he
build the big Tower with a big goatee or
W on it no no he didn't incredible okay
tempers and things I like events and
things that I hate things I like so
speaking of actual history that matters
there there is a fantastic fantastic
documentary that came out a little while
back called they shall not grow old
directed produced by Peter Jackson it's
the best thing that Peter Jackson has
done since Lord of the Rings obviously a
very different thing he colorized added
sound too and smooth out a bunch of
World War one footage and it
dramatically changes your take on and
your feelings about World War one
as things received into the mists of
history we tend to ignore them we
to dehumanize the people who are
involved in those historic occurrences
we tend to depersonalized from their
suffering and to feel that their
suffering occurred at a different time
black-and-white footage is one of the
things that does it everything that
exists in black and white feels like
it's just not it's almost half real well
Peter Jackson by recolor izing all of
this footage and changing the nature of
the adding sound suddenly world war one
feels like the Vietnam War or like the
Iraq war stuff that happened just
yesterday and that resulted in an
immense human carnage it's an amazing
film it does not try to undermine the
British cause in World War one but it
does point out the human suffering just
it should have won Best Picture last
year I'd never say that about a
documentary this should've won Best
Picture last year here's Peter Jackson
with they shall never grow old I was 16
years old and my father allowed me to go
I was just turned 17 at the time I was
NARAS 15 years when they came to us they
were frightening children and had to be
made into soldiers the pictures I gave
every part of my used to do a job
it's it's a transformative film it's an
amazing amazing accomplishment just a
filmmaking accomplishment so go check it
out it's available for sale on Amazon
right now they shall not grow old
there's there's a whole sequence that is
deeply affecting and moving where he
shows kind of slow-mo footage of these
guys in color and then he clips to them
after they've been killed it's it's it's
it's an amazing piece of filmmaking it
really is okay time for it some things
that I hate so Newsweek has a cover they
put Ilhan Omar on the cover and the
cover is a picture of her a close-up
picture of her don't worry guys we are
the ones obsessed with the fresh faces
not the media it is it is we we on the
conservative side were obsessed with
Ilhan Omar obsessed so it has a big
picture of her and then it says Ilhan
Omar the Democrats and Israel that's on
the cover and it says they tweeted this
out new cover story how ill Han is
changing the conversation about Israel
and up ending the 20/20 campaign now
weird I don't remember after Steve King
said his garbage about white nationalism
then putting him on the cover with Steve
King white nationalism and America and
the tweet how Steve King is changing the
conversation about race I don't remember
that I also don't remember them putting
Trump on the cover of the magazine when
he was talking about illegal immigration
and saying how President Trump is
changing the conversation about Mexico I
remember but L hen amar who's an open
anti-semite does not hide this fact
she's just changing the conversation not
about Jews but about Israel by the way
she's not changing the conversation this
has always been the conversation they're
a bunch of anti-semites who hate Israel
and use anti-zionism as a cover for the
fact that they do not like Jews Ilhan
Omar is one of those people the fact
that Newsweek is covering for her tells
you a lot about what you need to know
about the media
more generally okay other things that I
hate today
well by the way I forgot a thing that I
like I forgot a thing I like so I'll add
it in here the thing that I like they've
released a picture of an actual black
hole which basically looks like a donut
or the Eye of Sauron that's all that
that's all that it looks like but it is
pretty cool that theoretical physics
results in in real evidence a hundred
years later so that's kind of neat
anyway back to things that I hate
because come on there's a there's a
story from CBS News epic journalism in
here
the story is titled consent condom
requires four hands to open making
powerful statement about consent
powerful guys super powerful so I guess
what the consent condom is for is for
the guy evil enough that he is going to
rape a girl but woke enough that he buys
the condom that requires four hands to
open it so for that very small group of
guys who are who are woke enough to go
buy a condom that can only be opened by
two pairs of hands for that guy who is
also a rapist that's what this condom is
for I guess with consent at the
forefront of modern conversations about
sex says Sophie Lewis one company is
highlighting its importance in a unique
way
Argentinian company tulip n has created
a consent condom that requires four
hands to be open intending to raise
awareness about consent in the bedroom
if they don't say yes it means no the
tagline on a video demonstration says
consent is the most important thing in
sex yes I'm sure that this will fix
everything probably this will fix
everything that it requires for hands to
press the - to press buttons on the side
of the box to open the condom you've
changed the conversation guys finally we
solved rape good job everyone go home
happy well done I mean I guess we solved
rape except for that character from
Mortal Kombat who had four arms right
there's that guy in hand he had four
hands so the the four arms guy Goro so
Goro so Goro Goro I guess can still do
what he wants to do but everybody else
everybody else we've solved rape so
that's exciting stuff alright we will be
back here a little bit later today with
two additional hours Plus remember I'm
speaking at Grand Canyon University
tonight so if you are in the Phoenix
area head on over to Grand Canyon
University I believe it's sold out but
you may be able to get some scalp
tickets or something if you can't find
that then go to ya org slash live and we
are live-streaming
that event as well so you can just watch
that in the comfort of your own home but
if you wanna come out and experience the
joy go to GCU tonight I hope to see you
then
and if not we'll see you later today for
two more hours and if not then we'll see
you here tomorrow cuz we're a Content
machine gang I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody's Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show the left says
white nationalism is on the rise I say
they're real object is silencing
conservative speech we'll talk about
that and we've got the mail bag on the
Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew Clavin